and there are hundreds of thousands of
crosses on this place and it was a
stunning experience to be there it was
one of these places as soon as you walk
in you feel like you must be quiet just
immediately you must be quiet and as we
were walking you're going to hear this
you're going to hear hear this on the
documentary in a couple of episodes
um so father ginterest who is one of the
priests the priest really who showed us
around almost the whole country he said
as we were walking around he says you
know when people place their crosses
here some are happy because they're
celebrating something you know sometimes
they put one because a child was born or
baptized or something like that
sometimes they're sad they're
remembering someone who's departed or
they're praying for something that
they're really worrying about he says
walking around here and seeing all the
names and all of these languages on
these hundreds of thousands of crosses
he says this is almost like hearing what
God hears
and as you look around you see all these
prayers
that are ascending and you actually can
read them
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
so hello everyone I am very happy to be
here with Father Andrew damic and
Richard Roland and I father I always
pronounce your name wrong which I'm
sorry and I just realized it did it
again and uh but you know I love you uh
and for people that watch the channel
you are used to seeing them here uh I
feel like we are in some ways uh
partners in crime although we're not
committing a crime we're helping to
restore a certain way of seeing and a
certain way of participating in reality
and so Father Andrew and Richard went
together on a trip to Lithuania to
document you know the the relationship
between Orthodoxy and the Deep stories
that exist in Lithuania so I am excited
I haven't yet listened to the to the the
podcast I have to confess but I'm
excited too it's called The Wolf on the
cross an Orthodox Christian pilgrimage
in Lithuanian the first episode is
already out the wolf Lithuania before
the cross and so Father Andrew and
Richard I mean you start with Father
Andrew what possessed you to make us to
make something like this
uh there are so many reasons that I went
to Lithuania
um but for me probably the first one is
that my great-grandparents were from
there
and so um Lithuanian language and
culture were not in any way passed down
within my family it was erased
essentially after one in one generation
and so for me it was a kind of a
question mark in my own family's history
and um over the last 10 15 years or so
I've been sort of trying to fill in what
that question mark means for me
um and you know one of the things that I
discovered along the way is well there's
actually a seven or eight hundred year
history of Orthodox Christianity in
Lithuania and so that really sort of
doubled or tripled my desire to go there
and to connect with not just my family's
history but also the story of that place
and the story of my brothers and sisters
in Christ uh in that place and we found
it's really fascinating actually
um yeah so
it started with my great-grandparents
but then so many so many reasons yeah so
were your ancestors Orthodox or do you
know
um so my great-grandfather was Catholic
and my great-grandmother was Lutheran
which is a relatively a rare thing in
Lithuania most most people are Catholics
but my great-grandmother was from a I
think I'm not certain actually she was
from a culture that was essentially a
German culture in Lithuania that existed
for a long time and it became
lithuanianized yeah
um so her last name was was Germanic but
probably was altered in a Lithuanian way
and she always said to Lithuanian was
her first language and so Richard why so
what would why did you go what made you
want to go on this trip as well
um well actually it sort of started as a
joke
um father Father Andrew was like uh you
know I'm thinking about going to
Lithuania next year and almost as a joke
I was like well let me know I'll go with
you and uh you know then you know a year
later he's like so I'm going to lithium
you know how serious were you you know
you know and so uh so I went along to
help make the documentary Carrie father
Andrew's bags that kind of thing
but uh
but uh actually really I think there
were a couple of things one is
um I mean heck Europe is where the
history is from you know and so I've
been doing this Universal history thing
with you Jonathan for
well over a year now I think actually I
think it's maybe maybe like two years
like I don't however long since our
first video I don't even know but uh
we've been doing this thing for a while
and
um
and so this was just an opportunity to
kind of go over there and I've always
been interested in the Baltic states in
particular and in that culture
um for a couple of reasons one is
because it is the it's the geographical
meeting of east and west uh which is the
sort of uh the spiritual and cultural
place that I find myself in my life
right right at this kind of place where
uh East and West come together obviously
being a western person but being a
member of the Eastern Orthodox Church
um and trying to navigate those things
and figure some of those things out
Lithuania is the actual embodiment of
all of that
um and and also it's I don't know
there's a really interesting thing kind
of going on in in uh in Lithuania that
is present
I would say in Celtic culture
specifically like a Celtic Christian
culture as well which is the way in
which uh they were able to kind of
integrate their uh their kind of
mythical Pagan past
um and even you know like certain
artistic motifs
um you know there's the you know the
Celtic cross you know you can find
Celtic crosses in Ireland from before
the time of Christianity
um they were the Celts were already
making crosses Christianity just came
along and explained why you know and uh
the same kind of things going on in
Lithuania so you have you know the belt
Baltic Sun Cross which is like this you
know ancient kind of pagan symbol and
when Christianity came along uh we said
hey no problem actually this is uh is
you know crosses or a specialty of ours
let's put Jesus on it and uh now that's
probably one of the most recognizably
specifically Lithuanian things and then
um you know finally uh finally it was
just an opportunity to kind of to the
uh you know being in the Orthodox Church
in America
my particular parish and my particular
you know the tradition that I'm in
within the Orthodox Church is you know
from a very uh what used to be called
ruthenian background right
um but ruthenia is this land that uh
once encompassed much of what uh today
is modern day Ukraine and and Belarus
and and
um up into Lithuania proper and uh so in
that sense it was kind of a way to go to
the lands that you know my uh my
spiritual ancestors if not my um you
know my my physical ones as far as I
know I have no Lithuanian ancestors
although it's quite probable some of my
ancestors may have invaded Lithuania at
some point but I tried or tried right
yeah yeah
um but uh but it uh but it was a place
an opportunity to kind of go to the
place where this uh where my spiritual
ancestors are from and there's a a
particular connection to an icon of the
mother of God there that's related to
all that which maybe we'll talk about in
a minute so
wow so so you're made how many of us
Nine episodes is that is that my
understanding that's that's the current
plan is for Nine episodes and nine like
two hour episodes
basically so you you discovered a lot of
things there so what what what was like
what what's the driving
fourth like what is the thing that
really made you curious and excited
I think
um
there's a lot of pieces of Lithuanian
history including Lithuanian Orthodox
history
that are
he's really to the history of
um of Europe and of the Orthodox Church
right so I'll just give a couple of
brief examples
um one major element of Orthodox
Christian history that shaped uh even a
lot of American Orthodox history is
what's often referred to as the union
and that was that was the term at the
time you know so a union between some
Orthodox dioceses and the Roman Catholic
Church
and
um this became a turning point in
Orthodox history especially European
Orthodox history Well that took place in
what locally they called The
Commonwealth of two Nations but in
English sources it's usually called the
Polish Lithuanian Commonwealth and the
vast majority of that was in lands that
either at the time did or shortly before
belongs to the Grand duchy of Lithuania
and so there were lithuanians some of
whom were Lithuanian speaking
and some of whom were ruthenian speaking
but identified culturally as Lithuanian
or maybe we're polish speaking but
identified as Lithuanian who were deeply
involved in the Union uh and many who
were deeply involved in resisting the
Union uh there are Saints Orthodox
Saints from that period who were
involved in resisting the unions for
instance saint athanasius of breast
um
you know the so this is the Union is
called the union of breast and breast is
a place that was part of the grand duchy
of Lithuania at the time so that's
that's one element and you know
connected to that and this is something
that I think
probably a lot of American Orthodox
Christians are not aware of
um you know we have this common greeting
especially in Orthodox churches that are
uh Slavic background where people say
glory to Jesus Christ Glory forever
right
and I can't remember how to say the
other one in uh yeah
um
so that greeting actually is originally
as Lithuanian so they would say
glory to Jesus Christ and then they
would respond with amen which means
forever amen and this is the way that
all lithuanians greeted each other up to
World War II
you mean they greet each other just like
yeah on the street in the street
basically wow yeah this was not a church
thing yeah this was just a Lithuania
thing
and so uh when the union happened
that greeting of course which was old
even by that point so you know this
greeting is centuries upon centuries old
um it gets into the Union because these
people just keep living the way they
live and greeting each other the way
they always did and then you know when
many people of uh also this group is
called Greek Catholics even though
they're not ethnically Greek or
linguistic or Greek when many Greek
Catholics immigrate to the United States
they bring that greeting along with them
and of course many of those uh converted
to Orthodoxy in the early 20th century
late 19th early 20th century
at the same time there were groups back
in Europe who did the same thing
formerly Greek Catholic churches that
became Orthodox again
um and the greetings stuck uh it's it's
not actually a Russian Orthodox greeting
yeah it is a greeting that comes from
Lithuania but is part of the grand duchy
part of the Polish Lithuanian
Commonwealth and um so if you say that
to someone in Russia they may not know
how to respond to you because they've
never heard that before right um so it
becomes part of Orthodox Christian
culture here in America But ultimately
has its
um Origins there there was a moment that
we uh a a Sunday evening where we went
to a home in a village there
and uh uh the the parents of the the
wife of one of the priests who is
hosting us and he said uh now when you
meet her parents if you really want to
greet them in a in a beautiful way that
they will recognize as very respectful
and very Christian you should say this
and I said well what does that mean and
he tells me I was like wait a minute I
know this greeting you know he says he
says yeah uh all lithuanians said this
up until basically Nazis and Soviets
invaded and that's amazing push that out
and then now you get good morning good
day yeah yeah it's funny because I it's
funny because that we don't have that
greeting in in our Parish because it's a
french-speaking parish it has a
different maybe a different line and I
remember the first time I I mean a few
the few first times I wasn't used to it
right standing in front of a of a priest
and he says Glory Jesus Christ and I
just look at him and and it's like I'm
this idiot that doesn't know how to
respond to the greeting but I learned to
uh in time so
so Richard I I wanted to ask you in
terms of our Universal history so yeah
I'm sure you discovered or found ways
that the the Lithuanian culture connects
and so we want to hear about that yes
and so uh Father Andrew has graciously
assigned me a lot of the more uh uh
medieval history portions of the of the
documentary as well as uh writing a lot
of the Legends um one of the interesting
things that I think people will enjoy
about this documentary uh at least
symbolic World folks is the way in which
the um
will have legends about like the early
Lithuanian Grand Dukes for instance and
then also uh the the the the the
um hegeography of the early Lithuanian
Martyrs
um so that you get this in episode one
but those events uh both happen within a
generation of each other and so when I
uh when I kind of wrote those those
Legends wrote that hagiography and the
way that we kind of put it together you
get one at the beginning of the episode
one towards the end of the episode but
they're done by the same voice actor and
they're written in the same style and so
the point is actually to kind of show
the continuity of of time and of history
and of the world from the you know the
legend of the Iron Wolf which is this
let uh uh Pagan Lithuanian legend about
the founding of the city of illness
um and then a generation later The
Passion of The Three Holy Martyrs of
illness and that those two things kind
of flows together naturally in a way
that shows how so shows how things like
the Pagan histories of our past as well
as uh the stories of the
christianization and specifically the
way that that's embodied in the lives of
the Saints and also in the stories that
surround these these many wonderworking
icons of the mother of God that you'll
find in Lithuania the way that these
things just form a kind of a continuous
stream
so that's one thing that I'm really
excited about in the documentary
um another thing that's really
interesting is just the way in which uh
uh the grand duchy of Lithuania and then
the United polish Lithuanian
Commonwealth turns out to have been very
important in a lot of European history
in ways that uh the the version of
history that many of us grew up with
which was you know a little light on the
Middle Ages to begin with
um and then if you did get anything it
would be mainly from like a French and
French and English that's an English
perspective that's right yeah
specifically about how the English are
better than French
or in my case the opposite in your case
the opposite um actually yeah I mean
this is not related to anything at all
but one day we will do Universal history
video about Joan of Arc
um uh which I'm pretty uh who I'm very
interested in but uh of course growing
up I was told she was the villain really
like can you believe wow can you believe
that yeah well I didn't I didn't think
that's even possible how can you think
that first of all obviously people don't
hear from Saints and Angels yeah of
course yeah that's right but there's
that but also she was French so yeah so
that's that's better than that it's a
double whammy she was a girl a lot of
whammys there yeah anyway but uh that
aside
um one of the one of the uh I'll just
give another example that's like a
really weird thing so if you grew up in
any kind of like a
h Evangelical
um uh fundamentalist sort of reformed
kind of that uh stream that trajectory
uh you probably I mean like for instance
the churches I grew up in had a
Reformation Day celebration every year
uh we wouldn't celebrate All Saints Day
you know don't be crazy but instead we
would celebrate Reformation day
um uh as sort of like a a replacement
holiday for Halloween actually celebrate
on the same day oh really yeah we'd have
a big party people would dress up uh
people would dress up as like famous
reformers and um
um we actually had a girl one year that
came in a pickle barrel uh uh like had a
which is a specific reference to the the
stuff that happened in the life of
Martin Luther and
um uh he he married this at this uh this
ex-nun uh who's and by smuggling her out
of a Convent in a pickle Barrel so yeah
yeah anyway wacky times wacky times
truly wacky stuff like if you think
about uh symbolism of everything going
on there but uh one of the things that
we you know they would do is they talk
about all the like the early sort of
people they consider to be
proto-reformers uh among whom was a an
important Hungarian uh religious leader
named Jan Huss yeah John John Hudson in
English and
um uh well it turns out uh by the way
Yahoo is not a not a Protestant
um the big thing that he was kind of
fighting for was uh for
um uh we'll probably talk about him in
Universal history at some point too
because he's really interesting but the
bit one of the big things that he was
fighting for was for the uh uh the
reception of the Eucharist in both kinds
um in fact the hussite fashion uh fact
that the hussite faction who was a big
you know real really a stickler for this
we were called the utra quit utrequests
you know that are from the Latin like
meaning both kinds right yeah so uh at
this point in Western Europe there was a
common practice to only commune people
in the body and not in the blood and
only once a year and this is actually
the main beef that the hussites had so
you know it's there they weren't quite
Baptist you could say
um but uh so anyway but the hussites
were not just a religious movement they
were a major political movement
um and what most people do not know I
actually know this until very recently
as I was researching stuff for the
second episode is that um they wanted
their own kingdom and they wanted their
own King and so they actually invited
the grand Grand Duke vitotas who was the
you know the he's called the great he's
one of the main people who really tried
you know centuries before the before the
union he really tried to uh see if he
could unite eastern and western
Christianity
um he's a very interesting figure but
they actually invited him to the
hussites actually invited him to be
their King you know because they wanted
to have a Christian Catholic King over
them but but not the king of Hungary who
they weren't getting along with at the
time so anyway all of this stuff is just
hugely interesting
um and a lot of the a lot of the major
uh political figures uh that show up
especially in the history of the 14th
and 15th century in the grand duchy of
Lithuania and Poland eventually Kingdom
of Poland eventually become you know uh
married into or involved in all of the
most important dynastic struggles that
happen in the late Middle Ages so
um you know Lithuania is has although we
don't know much about it it has a strong
like it just has a strong presence or
kind of Invisible Presence to us and the
history of Europe yeah and I think the
reason why there's probably several
reasons but I think one of the big
reasons why that's the case is because
at the end of the 18th century the
Polish Lithuanian Commonwealth gets
divided up between three different
Empires and Poland and Lithuania as
separate countries cease to exist right
so you get the Russian Empire takes a
chunk and gets Lithuania basically yeah
um the prussians and then the
austro-hungarian Empire they each get
their own chunks and so like one of the
things that that we we get as a result
if we especially as Orthodox Christians
living in North America is the
conversation about Orthodox Christians
who lived in those lands is largely from
the point of view of Russia who kind of
subsumed that that region at the end of
the 18th century and had been kind of in
competition with it for a while up to
that
um and so as a result the the point of
view of people who lived in that area is
is largely largely gone and sometimes is
kind of denigrated as being like a
peasant culture or whatever like another
example is for instance is the practice
of holy supper which is very common
amongst many Orthodox Christians that
they do on Christmas Eve holy supper was
uh is a practice of the former polish
Lithuanian Commonwealth celebrated by
Catholics by Orthodox by Protestants and
still to this day in if you were to sort
of draw a map of eastern Europe and put
dots where everybody's celebrating holy
supper you would essentially see a map
of the Polish Lithuanian Commonwealth
over Christmas with uh somebody who is
uh polish Catholic by
um just you know culturally he's not
practicing or anything but he says oh
yes well we pulls we celebrate Christmas
actually on Christmas Eve and he what he
was talking about was holy supper like
that's the that's the Christmas
celebration you know we don't actually
do anything on Christmas day it's like
well
it's not exactly correct but but it's
just like that that memory of the Holy
supper was you know like still very very
uh potent for him yeah that's
interesting I didn't I like it's funny
because my wife is from Slovakia and she
says that Christmas is the 24th and I'm
like Chris is not the 24th this is the
25th it's like well in my country we
celebrated on the 24th and like it there
I'm saying it's Christmas Eve you're
celebrating Christmas we have this fight
like every 20 something you know 24
years you've had this fight yeah
actually is probably doing something at
home with her family having to do with a
particular meal the night before and it
was like that's because that area was
part of this Commonwealth that's super
interesting Slovakia so so it's almost
like Lithuania is a kind of Easter egg
especially for orthodox Christians kind
of hidden in everything yeah you know so
what is the state of the what is the
state let's say of of Orthodoxy today in
Lithuania what is it what did you find
there
so um there is a Russian diocese Russian
Orthodox Diocese of Lithuania right now
and this diocese arises really in the
19th century with a whole bunch of Greek
Catholics becoming Orthodox
um which from one point of view was a
sort of a mass conversion movement from
another point of view involved a lot of
government pressure
um both are probably true at the same
time so that's the origin of the modern
diocese there are about 50 or 60
parishes in the country
somewhere around a hundred thousand or
so people identify themselves as being
Orthodox Christians but only about two
or three thousand are actually in church
on a regular basis okay
um so uh but there are a number of
centuries-old churches there and some
incredible shrines
um for instance the the reliquary of the
three Martyrs of Vilnius in the Holy
Spirit Monastery uh their relics have
been incorrupt for 675 years and we
actually came home with relics of these
three Martyrs so if you're anyone's in
eastern Pennsylvania come to Emmaus and
you can venerate probably the only
relics of these Saints on the continent
very likely
um and so what about what about the are
there traces of the Greek Catholic or
the the the Orthodox let's say
a smell of Orthodoxy in Lithuanian
Catholicism still or has it been
completely subsumed by
as a matter of fact yes uh probably the
most obvious way
is that they have there are a number of
the Wonder working icons Lithuania which
are in Catholic hands right when you
look at it it's an Orthodox icon and
it's often mounted up behind a Catholic
Altar
um and they're they're venerated by both
Orthodox and Catholics and one of them
which of course is the one that I know
Richard is itching could talk about our
lady of the Gate of the Dawn
actually has a beast day on the Orthodox
calendar and that's the day after
Christmas so I have prepared some visual
aids Father Andrew one moment so our
lady of the Gate of the Dawn while
Richard is fetching the whatever he's
getting I'm sure he has a copy of it
yeah I'm sure it is
um is sort of the national icon of
Lithuania and uh it is in a gate
um so you can walk through the gate and
then up above the gate there's a chapel
and that's and that Chapel hosts the
icon and it is a stunning icon it is an
icon of the mother of God essentially as
she's described or as the church is
described because we know these are
basically the same thing yeah in
Revelation chapter 12. a woman clothed
in the sun with the moon beneath her
feet oh yeah oh I know that icon of
course round with 12 stars but this is
this isn't Lithuania this is it yes
yes yes yes yes yes wow so this
particular icon which uh First shows up
in vilness in maybe the 13th or 14th
century
um very old probably uh you know from
somewhere in the East uh but nobody
really knows for sure right
um
um it's put over the dawn gate of the
city of illness to protect it from
Invaders and the dawn gate is one of the
few of the original medieval uh Gates I
think the only one
yeah I was illness which still stands to
this day
um and so there's a beautiful Chapel up
on top of the gate now where you can go
and see the icon and venerate it uh the
actual thing is huge oh how besides it's
the size of like a wall I mean really
massive
um and of course and it has this
beautiful or I mean it has this this
like this sort of like the silver Risa
over it right but it's um but yeah it's
the original icon is massive I mean
um I've got a picture of myself standing
next to it it's probably five or five
feet across maybe maybe six feet tall
yes about right yeah and so is it is it
is the reason it's like the image you
showed us is that when you see or is
there another reason on top of it so uh
this this is this is like a kind of uh
uh you know just like a a printing with
like kind of a like gold foil or or
whatever over it yeah and it's
um
so the the Riza covers actually pretty
much everything but the face I think oh
not even the hands it covers
it doesn't cover doesn't cover the hands
yeah it doesn't cover the hands but if
you look at the uh original version of
the icon which is under the Riza which I
mean you can find pictures of this
online I'm about to show you one but
um you'll you'll notice if you're in
Eastern Orthodox Christian especially in
the kind of the Slavic tradition in
North America you'll notice that it
Bears a deep similarity to an icon which
Saint seraphim of sarov uh had in his
cell so this is a copy of that icon
and uh you can see it's basically the
same image it shows the mother of God
there's no moon here but it shows the
mother of god with their hands folded
over her chest yeah
um insane seraphim's icon there is
wording as there is in this one in Halo
around the Mother of God's had that in
slavonic is the refrain from the acaf
him Rejoice oh and what it bride so you
know the the icon became very popular
especially throughout the whole Grand
duchy of Lithuania the Polish Lithuanian
Commonwealth and so many copies were
made
um and it's generally believed that when
Saint seraphim I think visited Kiev at
one point that he was given a copy while
he was there
and so this is another like I said a
kind of another Lithuanian Easter egg
that exists for orthodox Christians and
uh you know Saint seraphim in many icons
is actually depicted praying in front of
an icon while he's kneeling on the Rock
there's an icon sometimes in a Cell
sometimes uh nailed to a tree and it's
if you look closely it is our lady of
the Gate of the dawn like there's just
no question this is that icon so the the
the the icon itself is quite unusual in
terms of Eastern icons most eastern
icons of the mother of God show her
holding the child yeah um and of course
the the kind of lore that's grown up
around this icon in this uh Slavic
tradition is that it depicts the mother
of God at the moment of the Annunciation
with her sort of her hands fold on her
chest in prayer her head bowed she's
giving her a scent yeah that makes sense
I mean it does look like the pose that
she takes in the Annunciation icon right
yes and so
um uh but the kind of the story about
how Saint Sarah from got that particular
icon is that uh when he was uh when he
was a young man before he was seraphim
or a saint he uh he went to the uh the
Kia of labra uh the great lava at Kiev
to get a blessing to become a monk and
he goes there uh and the Elder there do
you remember her her name Father Andrew
no I don't oh I'm sure he'll tell the
story in the documentary I I will tell
the story in the documentary and people
can we'll get them for the full version
we'll watch the documentary I'm spacing
out right now but uh the whole the Elder
there at the at the Key of lava at the
time
uh was one of these Saints who is a a
woman who disguised herself as a man and
became a monk and is living you know in
the cell there at the lava so at the
time it was you know he and people
didn't find out until after after her
death yeah you know and uh but so Saint
Sarah from goes to this this woman she
was from a uh she's from a kind of a
noble family with connections to uh
Belarus uh which is uh where this
particular icon Our Lady of the Gate of
the Dawn is um is very popular and very
revered and so um it seems
um and this has been the theory of a
couple of historians of iconography that
I've talked to about this the theory is
that uh that uh Steven probably was
given the this Icon by this this holy
Elder when he was at the Key of lava and
got a blessing to go to sarav and become
a monk
um and probably brought it with him from
there and so um and so it's got this
kind of deep connection of course seeing
seraphim is the uh is the the patron of
my Parish but also my own personal
patron saint and so this particular icon
has been you know as you can see many
years ago I actually even before I was
Orthodox I commissioned this copy of it
from an iconographer in St Petersburg
and it's been you know kind of
um you know definitely my favorite icon
of the mother of God and really
personally significant to uh to my life
and my prayer life and uh so so you know
for me going to see the the icon of Our
Lady of the gay of the Dawn this was a
it was a big deal yeah and it's it's
extremely beloved throughout Lithuania
every single Catholic Church you go to
and every single Orthodox Church you go
to has a copy somewhere we were told
even we were told even although there's
there's only maybe you know a very small
handful of Protestant churches in
Lithuania but we were told that you know
even even in some of those you can see
um I guess the only two Protestant
churches we went into were they didn't
have one up but uh we were told that
even especially like Lutheran parishes
often yeah we'll have one and if you go
to Lithuanian cemeteries which are a
fascinating place to begin with uh you
will see this icon on many tombstones
it's I mean she's just everywhere in
Lithuania everywhere
well
so if if we wanted to actually talk
about two things real quick that I think
uh if you want to say like are important
to me to kind of the symbolism of
Lithuania and that people will be
hearing about more in the documentary
um one thing would be the cemeteries and
the other thing that I would really like
to talk about is the is the sort of
weird uh uh in many ways kind of
abortive attempt to reconstruct Baltic
paganism in Lithuania no that's
happening now let's say there's been
that's right yeah there's a neopagan
movement there called room of uh
um which is
um
it's it's and what they do is they take
so so just as with almost any Pagan is a
European paganism there are no sources
there are no first-hand sources from
actual Baltic pagans uh instead what you
get is stuff that's survived in folklore
a lot of weird syncretistic stuff yeah a
bunch of mushrooms and Jung yeah right
exactly and in their case often they
would mix in stuff from uh Hinduism
really because because yes because so so
uh you know both Indian culture and
Lithuanian culture are Indo-European
cultures oh yeah so that's stretching
and have a well they have there's a
linguistic connection between the two so
Lithuanian is actually one of the most
archaic Indo-European languages and so
as a result many people have seen lots
and lots of very obvious cognates with
Sanskrit you're right
um and so as a result then there's this
kind of feeling like well the ancient
Indians the ancient lithuanians were
kind of maybe sort of doing the same
thing religiously which is just
hilarious yeah it is many thousands of
years are we talking about here a lot
yeah a lot of thousands of years wow
that's that's wild but I mean most of
the way that Lithuanian paganism has
kind of survived in Lithuania is
not through this neo-pagan movement
which is only just a few thousand people
at best okay um but rather it's it's
it's the the survival of Legends that
have become if not explicitly
christianized they have become Christian
friendly I mean basically basically uh
mythology turning into fairy tales right
exactly like a a great example and
you'll hear this in the first episode is
the The Legend of the Iron Wolf which is
a pagan story happening with pagans and
includes a pagan priest interpreting a
pagan uh you know uh Duke's dream right
and yet in very Christian Lithuania the
Iron Wolf is everywhere in Vilnius it's
one of the symbols of the Armed Forces
but there's no sense of like secretism
to it at all uh the the sort of the
fangs of of paganism have been
completely removed yeah but I mean it's
like that's what Richard and I have been
exploring for the past several months
that you see the same you know in in
Byzantine culture they had kept the the
Greek uh the Greek plays they they had
kept you know Homer they they would read
these it was part of their kind of
common imagery comment culture but but
there was a hierarchy and that's I think
that's that's the way to understand it
that there's there's a proper hierarchy
these stories can often survive as kind
of you know as Folk and and common
things that we hold in common yeah I
know Richard you're going to mention
cemeteries this is something that I
think is really worth talking about yeah
yeah so I'll come to that in a second I
wanna I do want to share like one little
detail I'm gonna actually share one of
the things that Father Andrew wasn't
there for oh
um it's true yeah uh so we went to we
went out to uh uh during the trip we
went out to the city of Carlos which is
up near the uh the Baltic are you
thinking of clip I don't know why I said
conus is in the middle yeah I've been
I've been just like looking at these
names while I write this episode until
my my eyes get crossed yes thank you all
these names that start with k it's true
there's a bunch so we won't have to
claipita uh which is a city there by the
Baltic and then one and then uh took a
ferry across to this long spit of land
it's actually made up of a number of
Dunes
um uh what are called parabolic Dunes
they're basically giant sand dunes that
get up and walk every once in a while
and uh in fact the ones on uh on this uh
this this land formation called the
cronians pit uh they're actually
um uh
some of them are named after like The
Villages that they have swallowed you
know over the centuries which is pretty
awesome and a really beautiful place I
mean truly one of the most beautiful
places I've ever been in my life
um one of the interesting things about
it was the uh uh you know we went to a
place there uh called the hill of
witches
um so the hill of witches was one of
these things that was kind of bought and
paid for
by the Soviets as like a way of trying
to undermine Catholicism Lithuania more
or less right right uh so basically it's
this hill and these Trails like these
hiking trails and you go up and uh the
word that's being translated as which in
English really means like it can mean
like fairy but also like demon or imp or
something like this but it's basically
mythological folklore figures
like yeah a character from folklore yeah
and um
and uh and and so they there are these
sort of like uh carvings and statues of
all these different figures done in kind
of a traditional Lithuanian mode
um and so these aren't I mean they're
not objects of worship there aren't you
know nobody comes up there and offers
sacrifices or there's no altars up there
yeah yeah but it was it definitely uh
uh it definitely felt like this very
sort of weird uh
this weird kind of wild liminal sort of
a space
um and so we had a great time hiking and
everything and then uh Father Andrew I
think went back to the hotel and
um or did you go back to the hotel or
just go somewhere to rest so we went to
that Hill uh together it was the day
before that you went somewhere else on
the spit if I recall
or maybe the day after but but in any
case in any case
um
I think it was the day after because we
went uh the next morning we got up we
went swimming in the in the in the sea
and then
um and then we took this
this no maybe it was after anyway I it's
okay I was very jet lagged at that point
we were very liminal space you came back
right to remember things as they happen
so it was really interesting because we
it was the evening it was the evening
and uh we were making our way on this
long hike up to the top of the Dooms so
you can hike up to the top of the dunes
and look over them over the border into
kaliningrad which is technically part of
Russia the kalinograd oblast
um and um it's funny because I was at
the I was in an airport the other you
know a couple months ago but I was
telling somebody about the coronian spit
just like a random person in the airport
uh because this is what it's like to
travel with me and um and uh this this
girl turns around and her eyes get real
big and she says I'm from kalitting grad
he's like nobody knows about this anyway
it was it was a it was kind of a neat
meeting but um anyway so
we're hiking up these dunes and
um I mean really beautiful kind of a
silent uh Forest so it's all on Sand and
you know how like after a snowfall
everything is kind of hushed because the
snow is kind of sucking up all the sound
exactly like that but no snow yeah right
so there's just hush all you can really
hear is the crunch of the sand under
your feet you're in this Pine Forest I
told somebody you know if a uh if a
white stag ran across the path right now
I would not be surprised yeah uh so we
make it up to the top of the the dunes
um actually while we're hiking up
there's like somebody like some some
neo-pagan group somewhere in the woods
is like they're they're doing something
right and so they're they're beating
drums and like the drums are like the
only thing you can hear in the forest
and you know it's way off in the
distance it was very eerie and we made
it up to the top of the dunes and they
have this they built this massive
Sundial at the top of the largest Dune
there
um and the Sundial is
um it's weird because it uses a bunch of
Norse runes which are maybe not quite
you know which are different yeah maybe
for Lithuania but all paganism is runes
all right I know look there's Norse
people right across the Baltic Sea well
I know there certainly were you know
Norse people in Lithuania at various
points but but I mean this wasn't being
done to make historical reference they
were trying to do this to make it a
little like seem like sort of like
vaguely neopic and uh massive Sundial up
at the top of the dunes
um so it was it was a very interesting
place and I'm I'm you know as we're
getting getting towards that part of the
documentary I'm still kind of like
mulling over the experience there
because uh
you know uh definitely
in in what is overwhelming the you know
a Christian place right uh there is uh
uh there are these like little bits of
uh I don't know how to say like fairies
hanging out in the corners right in a
usually in a I think at a pretty
harmless way but um you know just
connecting this to some of the other
Universal history
uh discussions that we've had and I know
there are other places in the world that
are like this as well but it was really
strange and at times very intense to
kind of come into contact with this so
yeah the other thing that we'll mention
real quick were the uh the graveyards
which were absolutely incredible
um here in the US I don't know how
things are in Canada land but here in
the US uh graveyards are
um just sort of like mass-produced rows
on rows of headstones they're all the
same there's nothing really particularly
beautiful or sacred about them it's more
like how can we if
pack as many people into these spaces as
efficiently as possible yeah and I think
the further you get away from like the
East Coast the more that seems to be the
case yeah I think you're right I think
you're right we have some good old
cemeteries here in Emmaus Pennsylvania
but still there they do not compare to
Lithuanian cemeteries if you go out into
the countryside uh even here in Texas
going to East Texas which is where I'm
from there are some some like nice old
you know Church graveyards
um but generally speaking there are a
bunch of generic rest land flower land
you know or accepting land right yeah
and just like seas and seas of of uh
indistinguishable headstones yeah when
we were in Lithuania we visit we ended
up
peering over the wall of a couple of
cemeteries
but there's one in particular that we
went to and we scoured it
and that's because we went to the
hometown of my great grandfather and
which is called kudirko's namistis which
is way on the western edge of Lithuania
right next to the the Russian part the
kalini oblast which traditionally by the
way that land that that oblast that is
belongs to Russia now it's disconnected
from the main body of Russia
traditionally that's called Lithuania
minor so it belonged to Lithuania back
in the day at various points in history
um so kudukus Nemesis is right up
against that border and there's a little
river that separates the two and
um we started walking through that
Cemetery which thank God is not a huge
Cemetery
um and we were looking for my ancestors
because I knew that a bunch had been
buried there I Found Records indicating
that but I I didn't know exactly where
and after some time you know thank
goodness we had someone along with us
who read Lithuanian who was able to say
this one says so my family's name you
know this is funny you you begin by
mispronouncing my name if I if my
great-grandfather left it alone you
might find it easier to say
is our traditional name and so
um the the priest who is guiding us that
day father of Vladimir
he's pointed at one particular one he
says this says of the Jamaica family on
it here in Lithuanian he said this is it
and it is literally the place that my
ancestors are were buried for
Generations
no one in my family uh the American
branch of my family had been back in
almost a hundred years yeah
so are these the were they Stone
monuments or were they these wooden
crosses that we see like this image we
have in Lithuania like these wooden
wooden crosses and stuff we should talk
about the Wooden Crosses in a second we
will come to that in a second yeah yeah
but no these are these are stone for the
most part there were I guess a few
wooden grave markers like really old
traditional ones
um and in fact uh one of the places we
went to when we were on the cronian spit
was to the we went to the the house of
of Thomas mon a famous German novelist
actually one of my favorite writers uh
he wrote a really interesting novel on
the life of Joseph
um called the Young Joseph where Joseph
and his brothers
um super interesting I worth reading but
uh but he wrote that a novel while he
was living on this this house this
really beautiful old kind of traditional
uh German house that there were a lot of
Germans who kind of settled in that
particular part of Lithuania along the
Baltic and so we went to his house and
then after we went to his house there
was a nearby Lutheran Church and so we
went we looked at that and then um this
is part Father Andrew wasn't there for I
think and then we went to uh this old
Lithuanian graveyard um Lutheran
Lithuanian graveyard in this case but
really uh really
old-fashioned in that all of that the
markers were these wooden crosses but
there would be different kinds of
crosses uh depending on um depending on
you know who the person was and how old
they were so that if you if you sort of
knew like how to read the crosses you
could say well this kind of cross for
somebody who died when they were young
just kind of cross for a mother Etc
um and actually we found uh we found the
grave Graves of two Orthodox Christians
um in that graveyard while we were kind
of looking around so they died there and
we're buried there some time ago but
um but most of the grave markers were uh
were Stone in most of the cemeteries uh
almost all of them I would say almost
all but I'd say a good third if not half
um had had this icon wow on it yeah wow
yeah yeah and and one thing that really
makes a Lithuanian grave different from
most of the ones you see in North
America and you see some in North
America like this but almost all of them
in Lithuania are like this is that the
grave plot is outlined usually in stones
or sometimes uh cement you know
um to to Mark the border of it
and then inside that border there is
basically a small garden planted with
lots of flowers and so forth and so uh
when you walk through it instead of the
graveyard being essentially taken care
of by some company that owns the place
and mows the lawn every single grave is
immaculately cared for by family members
and lithuanians will visit the graves of
their family at least twice every year
no matter where they live in the country
now fortunately you can get from one
corner of the country to the farthest
Way Corner in about three and a half
hours yeah so it's not hard you know to
to do it but but they will go twice a
year so they will go on the anniversary
of that person's death and make sure
that the grave is very well taken care
of and they also go
around November 1st and 2nd which is uh
sort of a two-day holiday that they
called velenis which is connected of
course to the Catholic All Saints and
All Souls day and if you go especially
on those days
you will see that there are candles on
every single grave and so it's almost
like there's a second City
you know there's the one city where the
living are and then there's this other
city where the dead are wow um and it is
a very very serious time for lithuanians
um for veleness and uh they they're it's
it's considered to be a a stain on your
family
if the graves of your family are
neglected like it's a big shame you
don't let that happen
so Father Andrew what
what do you hope to accomplish like with
this documentary what is it that you
were what is it that you want to bring
to the world I guess
um number one a bunch of stories that
people have never heard that I think are
going to be not just fascinating and
entertaining in some cases but I hope
edifying
um one of the ways that I know how stuff
that I make is is being received by the
is by the email that we get
and I tell people that uh with almond
Soul which is the podcast that Richard
and I do together we get the longest
emails so Tolkien Fanatics you know
sending us long multi-paragraph emails
you know
um and then and then with Lord of
spirits which I do with Father Stephen
DeYoung we get the weirdest emails
uh deeply deeply weird many of them not
all of them but but deeply
but uh with the wolf on the cross we get
the most heartfelt emails and it's been
really interesting to me to see that
because I thought okay well I care
deeply about these stories will anyone
else you know and uh I've heard actually
from a bunch of Lithuanian Americans
including some Orthodox clergy
saying that they were in tears listening
to what we were talking about but even
people with no Lithuanian Heritage at
all saying I've never heard this before
and why did no one ever tell me and
especially they were struck by the story
of the Three Martyrs of illness which is
just such a powerful powerful story and
if you listen to that first episode
number one Richard's writing is Top
Notch so good job Richard in writing
that story and then we also hired uh a
voice actor named Brandon Talley and his
performance is top notch and um one of
the things you'll also hear this uh this
documentary is very different from every
other ancient Faith Radio podcast
particularly not just in terms of the
content but also the production value
so not only you're going to hear you
know the two of us uh telling stories
and doing narration uh but you're also
going to hear lots of of interviews that
we recorded on site while we were in
Lithuania you're going to hear voice
actors you're going to hear ambient
music that's as appropriate to whatever
the story that's being told so for
instance during the the the hagiography
of the Three Holy Martyrs you're gonna
hear this very epic adventurous sounding
music because it's an epic tale but also
even there's sound effects right so like
we tell stories about battles and you
hear battle sounds you know in connect
with this and and honestly there is as
far as I'm as far as I know there is no
other Orthodox Christian Media in
English podcasts like this with this
kind of production work and so my hope
is that people will feel that they are
there with us
that they are taking the the trip with
us that they're on the pilgrimage with
us like like another great example we
talked about crosses
um there's a very famous place there
called the hill of crosses where people
go on pilgrimage and they bring across
all along their pilgrimage and then when
they get there they place it and they
will write the names of people on that
cross that they want to pray for
um and there are hundreds of thousands
of crosses on this place and it was a
stunning experience to be there was one
of these places as soon as you walk in
you feel like you must be quiet just
immediately you must be quiet and as we
were walking you're going to hear this
you're going to hear hear this on the
documentary in a couple of episodes
um so father ginthrus who is one of the
priests the priest really who showed us
around almost the whole country he said
as we were walking around he says you
know when people place their crosses
here some are happy because they're
celebrating something you know sometimes
they put one because a child was born or
baptized or something like that
sometimes they're sad they're
remembering someone who's departed or
they're praying for something that
they're really worrying about he says
walking around here and seeing all the
names and all of these languages on
these hundreds of thousands of crosses
he says this is almost like hearing what
God hears
and as you look around you see all these
prayers
that are ascending and you actually can
read them I should I should just note
that it typically the way it works is
somebody goes on a pilgrimage to the
hill of crosses as we did you have a
cross you write the names of the people
that you want to pray for and then you
carry it with you on your pilgrimage so
you get to the hill of crosses where you
plant it and then you
and then you leave it there so there
were I mean hundreds of thousands I
think is too conservative and estimate
especially since a lot of times you'd
have a big cross and and there would be
hundreds of rosaries just hung on it
left there but yeah right so I mean you
know if you wanted to count really all
the crosses there including the small
ones it'd have to be a million it's
impossible yeah and and you know one of
the things about this place so it's it's
been hosting crosses probably for
centuries now
uh during the Soviet period the Soviets
would go in and burn them down and and
bulldoze them down
um and yet in the middle of the night
people would go out there and put their
cross back and so it had the effect of
this Forest getting burned down and then
just springing up again regrowing
overnight yeah and so it became a symbol
of resistance to an atheist domination
of the country of an occupation of of
you know Soviet uh demonic evil and so
one of the things that I want people to
walk away from not just from this story
of the hill of crosses you're going to
hear it over and over again over and
over again uh is this sense of Keeping
the Faith and loving Christ in the midst
of very difficult circumstances
um you know Orthodox Christianity has
been a minority in that country and
throughout its entire history throughout
the whole history Orthodoxy has been the
minority it was never the state religion
even when Grand Dukes were Orthodox
which there's one that we know was
there's one that was Catholic and then
Orthodox and then Catholic again uh
probably
um and um but then even you know frankly
you know our our Catholic friends
suffered a lot hot under uh under
Russian imperial Rule and under
certainly absolutely under nazian Soviet
rule in the late 20th century and and it
is an extremely inspiring story uh to to
hear about how these people kept their
faith in the midst of this and um I mean
it was amazing like we were walking
around and people say oh yeah there was
a Lenin statue over here we tore that
one down
you know
um and so you know it's hard to think
about that you know to to to to conceive
of what it must be like yeah you have
lived under that domination and then to
come out and have this sense of
solidarity and love like the Lithuania
gained its independence from the Soviet
Union
through singing actually uh a singing
Revolution which you're gonna hear that
story towards the end so you know we
don't want to spoil it so everybody
go and check out
the series The Wolf and the cross I am
going to listen to the first episode you
know by tomorrow morning and now you've
got me all excited about it so thanks
for your love and uh dedication to this
project but also just to helping people
ReDiscover the ancient stories how they
connect together with our faith and so
Father Andrew and Richard thanks for
your time thank you very much for having
us Jonathan